so let's have a look at this we can see
where we've got to go see where we've
got to go and before we actually get
started on the audre or calculus I want
us to think as much as possible about
what this can tell us right now before
we even prepared today but just by a
Louisiana can we interpret anything
useful about this so let's just have a
look at this platform ocean just based
on that statement okay number one you
know a puff of the fact that the head
tells you number one you know it that's
in the four X double dot equals in fact
let's write it underneath X double dot
equals negative n square X right so this
is a simple harmonic this matches super
pilot one Englishman right can you tell
me some more things what else can you
squeeze out of that equation
okay so we're looking at this n square
key right we see the n must be three
right now I just want you to point out I
just want to point out normally if I
didn't have if I didn't have a well if
that n value was just one okay what kind
of truth which is like what's the period
of a normal retreat functions Simonides
gave me two pi right now because I'm
actually putting it N equals three out
the front so this could have been like a
sine 3t plus alpha or a cos 3t plus
alpha okay that means the period is no
longer two pi the period is going to be
two pi love through I get three copies
of the whole graphing we goes up and
down three times within that normal not
to two pi okay that's cool either the
period do I know a T is there anything
else I can squeeze out of this equation
fantastic very good you can see because
he there's no X take away whatever okay
the center of motion must be the origin
okay so it's about x equals zero I'm
gonna write that down
there's the centered mission they test
it okay I think we've squeezed a lot out
of that the very what what is that one
two three four five you count the equal
sign symbols okay I mean this is
something that mathematicians love to do
condense as much money as we can into a
very very small space can we move on to
this next bit what can you tell me again
without putting pen to paper
what can you interpret off of this you
know suggest something okay
so you said a couple of things there
okay the first thing is when I see
something like say T equals zero I think
initially or vice versa
I see initially and I think T equals
zero when I see V equals zero at rest is
exactly what I should think or
alternatively if I see the words at rest
I should think V equals zero okay where
is it at rest it's at rest at x equals
five there are four simple harmonic
motion this is draw a really quick and
dirty graph for ourselves right if I
draw a very steep I don't know anything
that time so I don't know where to start
and enough it starts at the origin I
don't know if it starts at extremity or
somewhere in between so I'm just going
to imagine suppose it does that like
that's just a simple one I know I can
draw it on this axis because as Brendon
point out the center of motion is the
origin and there's the x-axis and
there's zero so what we say is where are
these points where V is equal to zero at
x equals five it's going to be that
point right that's a secondary point
it's at rest so the next thing that
wraps i which is actually our next
another step of logic is oh if that's
where it's at rest that's important to
me because that's the amplitude right
that's the opportune which means that
the other place I'm at rests which I can
conclude from this is x equals negative
5 it's it's all the way on the
opportunity okay so without actually
doing any calculations or
differentiating or integrating whatever
I'll render a whole lot about this about
this version okay
I want you to get in the habit of
thinking before riding think before
writing because that guides the writing
that you will then do it okay it gives
you the most efficient point now that
I've got all of this background now I
can have a go of this question it says
find V squared as a function of X okay
you know a whole lot of equations about
simple harmonic motion now if this is
where I'm going what do you think is the
best starting point suggestion was do DX
ha ha v squared okay pause for a second
why is this the obvious choice there are
two reasons okay firstly this is in
terms of displacement displacement so
you can't use V DB or DX you're kind of
gonna be stuck without help
there's another really obvious thing
which is I won't be squared and this is
the form that has av Swit probably some
enough to muck about with a little bit
but a huge amount so this is the obvious
choice so this is acceleration which
I've been given in the question as minus
or negative balance okay all right so
based on how I've been given information
about the version and where I'm trying
to go I decide this is my best starting
point
okay what would you like me to do now
okay let's integrate with respect to X
I'm going to encourage you as much as
possible when you're describing what
you're doing to a friend or to yourself
now we know if you need to go with
respect to a variety of things so don't
you say it's a great tell me what you're
integrating with respect to and it's X
in this case on the left hand side
you're gonna get hartley squared over
the right would you like me to write
this has been my convention I'm just
gonna say half C so they end up with
just to see once I doubled okay so I'm
going to say that guy is constant is it
real number and now I'm just gonna
multiply through that gives me this what
do you think okay I wish the way there
I need V squared as a function of X I
sort of want to get rid of this constant
don't know how will I do that yeah good
are you starting get the sense you're
always going to get a closer when you
integrate and you're always going to use
some conditions in order to work out
what that close for you so let's keep
going when x equals 5 V equals 0
why does that so I'm just going to
substitute here what are we gonna get
here negative 9 times 25 is 0 squared 9
times 25 that's that's one short of 10
times 25 so it's 250 and taken away so
that's gonna be 225 and I can sub that
back in I've got this I notice these
positive and I've got a minus 9x squared
there so I'm gonna write C up to 24 what
do you think okay okay now I'm going to
do one more thing here like I'm finished
I've done but mathematicians were always
looking for patterns and when we see
patterns we always think through why is
that so you can see here there's an
obvious factorization I can do here at
all not an obvious it's a very simple
one because this 225 came from 9 times
whatever I can obviously take a factor
of 9 out of it yes to hear that so I'm
gonna write 9th at the front which gives
you 25 takeaway X square yeah that's
good now I'm not I'm just gonna pause
that